When I was a kid, we got a new twisty tube-slide
at the elementary school.
Kids liked to clog it up on purpose, with
the kid at the bottom stopping and holding
everyone else in the pipe.
Some kids thought it was a riot, but I felt
trapped and immediately had a sense of dread.
I screamed, the kids unclogged, and I was
instantly uncool.
Was that claustrophobia?
Or something else?
In 1879, physician Dr. Benjamin Ball observed
two patients in Paris who, curiously, couldn't
stay in their apartment with the doors closed
without anxiety, and a third who was climbing
Saint-Jacques Tower, and felt an overwhelming
urge to flee.
She ran to the exit, "dashing her head" in
the process.
Apparently, the urge immediately vanished
upon reaching the open air.
Ball dubbed this bizarre feeling "claustrophobia,"
and the 1881 American Journal of Insanity
called it "a special form of delirium, characterized
by a 'fear of closed spaces;'" today they
include narrow spaces with enclosed ones.
The list of spaces is long, including subways,
elevators, rooms without windows, public bathrooms,
tunnels, cars, hotel rooms, planes and so
on.
And even THINKING about it can trigger an
attack… sorry.
Most people who live with it don't get it
formally diagnosed, because there's no need
to do so, their own fear causes those affected
to spend much of their lives avoiding trigger
spaces.
The National Health Service in the UK says
10-percent of the population is affected by
claustrophobia, though studies find only about
four percent will suffer from full-blown attacks.
I call it an attack, because psychologists
and psychiatrists connect it to anxiety disorders,
believing it's essentially a short-lived panic
attack.
It might be caused by some kind of childhood
trauma.
For example, losing one's parents in a crowded
place, getting stuck in a hole (or a slide?)...
it's really hard to say.
Since the late 19th century, researchers have
been digging into this crazy fear, and found
very little solid ground.
A 2007 study in the Journal of Magnetic Resonance
Imaging found women were far more likely than
men to experience claustrophobia, and a study
in the journal Cognition in 2011, found it
may have to do with the invisible bubble of
"personal space" we all project around us.
Most people's personal space extends only
as far as we can reach, but people with claustrophobia
may be projecting their personal space beyond
their reach!
Thus, when someone violates that territorial
bubble, the person experiences a panic attack!
Researchers think this disorder may have a
connection to acrophobia, or a fear of heights;
as people with claustrophobia seem to underestimate
horizontal distances the way acrophobics do
with vertical ones.
Essentially, they believe the room is smaller
than it really is.
This study is about as far as we've come to
understanding the disorder.
Perhaps it's a defense mechanism, and some
are simply more sensitive to it…
There does seem to be a genetic component
as well.
A 2013 study in Translational Psychiatry found
a single mutation on gene Gpm6a causes "claustrophobia-like"
behavior in mice.
Plus, a study in Psychiatry and Clinical Neurosciences
found people with panic disorders had significantly
smaller amygdalae: the section of the brain
that processes fear!
In the end, they're still trying to figure
out WHY some people experience claustrophobia.
As with most anxiety disorders, there's no
true "cure."
Symptoms can be managed, but if the phobia
is severe, specialists will recommend exposure
therapy -- where the claustrophobic person
would be walked through imagining, and then
experiencing the things that cause the fear
until they, essentially, get over it.
It's rough, but so far, is the best we have.
More research is, for sure, needed.
What do you think?
Have
you experienced claustrophobia?